In the new space for the getFriends method I want to start by creating a string
that I can use to collect all of the names. Now I'll want to add all of the
friends. So I'll loop through all of the friends, one at a time, and I'll add
the separator and the ith friend's name onto that variable I was using as the
collector. But as this is right now it's going to print out a separator before
the fist name. So I need to look for a special case. In the regular case, where
we're not looking at the very first friend, we'll add the separator and the
friend's name. But if we are looking at the very first friend, then we just add
the friend's name. I'll just fix a couple syntax errors, and I'll remember to
return that variable that I used to collect all the names and now when I run
the tester, I can see that it works with whatever kind of separators I put in,
whether it's a semicolon, a vertical bar, or a unicode heart.